now people are going after you
uh acting as if we all know for certain
it came out of a lab the truth is we are
still
looking through a glass darkly because
we just don't have the data
you look at my emails i never in the
email said anything derogatory
about president trump
well the true mark of someone is if they
look good even when their personal
emails come out so you pass the test
that very few of us
would pass
so dr fauci how much money did you give
or that you know was given to the wuhan
institute and did you know they were
doing gain of function
she didn't ask that many in the media is
still fawning over dr anthony fauci
despite
newly uncovered emails from the early
early days of the pandemic
a new york post op-ed says this the
correspondence
make it clear that dr fauci's private
beliefs
have been radically at odds with his
public guidance to
u.s leaders and the american people
worse
the emails reveal a bureaucrat more
interested in protecting communist
china's public
image than finding the truth about the
coronavirus
former white house chief of staff mark
meadows ripped the doctor's efforts to
spin
what he said is in those emails
the interesting thing here tonight
though is you hear dr
fauci trying to change the narrative yes
listen this
this is not just about what happened in
a wu la
wuhan lab this is what actually happened
with dr fauci in the early days of the
the coronavirus outbreak dr fauci has
been flip-flopping i mean there's more
flip-flops on dr
fauci than you'll find on a north
carolina beach in july
joe concha media and politics columnist
for the hill and fox news contributor
joe always great to have you on the
program so we really got into it with
mark thiessen who
wrote a great washington post op-ed on
the semantics and all the details of
what needs to be looked at
i want to know where is the media on
this this is your expertise what's
happening with the story
the number one question dr anthony fauci
should be asked in
any interview and you talked about it
with mark thiessen
just that last segment is how can you
say
that china is trying to get to the
bottom
of this and if we say nice things about
them then they'll be cooperative
with us when considering that the
chinese announced
not too long ago that they had closed
their investigation
into coronavirus it happened in a wet
market and that's the end of it and
they're not going to cooperate in any
way shape or form so sir how could you
possibly defend the chinese
given their actions in closing this
investigation that's a pretty good
question i think we can start with
or you were made aware by other
scientists that this possibly could be a
lab leak
as much as a year ago and you continue
to deny it that's interesting as well or
how about
arguing in one email that retail mass
may not be very effective
against coronavirus or the fact that on
two occasions you share documents
that pertain to gain and function
research dangerous
research but instead these questions
aren't being asked at all we saw those
interviews yesterday harris where it was
like the propping up
of a politician named andrew cuomo it
felt very much the same way
so i i do want to go deeper on that
aspect of it
because it matters what this doctor says
because so many people
listen to him and many in the media lift
him up
look i i know you saw the montage of
pictures and reporters and anchors
right coming into you i mean they are
fawning in epic proportions
what's in it for them with that i'm not
sure it's a big disconnect harris with
the american people erasmus poll just
this week
found that two-thirds of americans
thinks that dr fauci has been operating
in seeing this pandemic through a
political prison which is not what the
nation's top doctor
is supposed to be doing and i even saw
one cnn correspondent
who actually criticized this network for
quote
covet origin focused news
all right can you imagine this these are
the most important
topics questions of our lifetime where
did this virus begin
how did it be how did it originate and
what did the chinese know and when did
they know and the reason why these
answers are so important harris
is so we can prevent covid 2.0 pandemic
covet 22
covid 28 so that's the criticism of this
network
that it's too coveted origin focused
well that's a criticism that this
network should embrace because anybody
who heard that argument is now dumber
for having seen it i've had an american
general
jack keane tell me that they have 75
labs in china and many of them do
what wuhan was doing they're they're
looking at gaining function they're
looking at viruses and maybe they're not
handling them right
and we have no transparency with that
process so
and look at the results how much we
focus
but you and i've got questions i want to
get to facebook real quickly
facebook will reportedly announce as
soon as today that it plans to end its
controversial policy that mostly shields
politicians from the content
moderation rules that apply to other
users it would be a sharp reversal
that could have huge ramifications for
how elected officials use the social
network
your reaction amazing is something like
86 percent of americans now
get their news online a lot of them get
them through twitter
and through facebook they are publishers
let's make that very clear
and the funny thing is that they say i
read in one story quote the change comes
after the oversight board
an independent group funded by facebook
to review its thorniest
content rulings it is not in any way
shape or
form this oversight board this pulte
bureau an independent board in any way
shape or form because then you wouldn't
see all these rulings
against conservatives and never touching
the blue team so
yeah that's what's uh ruling us at this
point in terms of the content that we
see
a social media oligarchs that are
faceless and we really have no idea
what they're doing or what they're
deciding because there's no due process
in these decisions
harris wow joe concha thank you very
much